on the mound bob you'd have to say maybe
the most consistent starter the pirates
have had all year j.t brubaker makes his
15th start oh two from him had a swing
and a miss struck him out with the
slider down on the way perfectly place
one out being aggressive pounding the
zone
gets ahead finishes
nice little breaking ball that breaks
down and away willie adamus will be the
hitter swinging a high fly deep left
center field headed towards the largest
part of the ballpark gone
one nothing brewers with one swing from
willy adams he got a hanging slider and
did not miss it my goodness the deepest
part of the ballpark out over the notch
out there in left center well rockhouser
looking for a little bit of a turnaround
here he's given up nine earned runs in
his last two starts best ground ball
pitcher in the big leagues 3-2
and that one's on the edge
come back sinker and a strikeout adrian
hauser that pitch right there if he's
commanding that one it's going to be a
long night for the pirates one up and
one down on just one pitch chase
peterson
and he hits that one well that's got a
chance to fly that is going to be up and
out of here wow
off the batter's eye
jays peterson
puts a charge into one his third homer
and the keystone combination each with
homers here tonight at thomas and
peterson two-nothing milwaukee here's
jackie bradley jr
there's a drive into center field going
back on it is reynolds at the wall it's
up and out it hit the top of the wall
jackie bradley jr sends it out of here
another home run for the brewers it's
three nothing here's ben gamel
what
driving one to center field and look at
this off the wall in center for gamble a
curveball that just launched it hammered
it yeah that ball bounced past jackie
bradley now ground ball can get your
runs phillip evans he bounds one onto
the third baseman that'll score the run
urriasa across the first and that scores
gamble give evans a run back again the
pirates are on the board it's three to
one luis urias will start here's the 3-2
and could not hold up
well that sliders worked for brubacher
today when he's gotten it down in the
way like that one out here's the one two
from brubacher
went inside on him and struck him out
with a fastball
yellow just gone two outs 94. firm right
under the hands
jacob stallings leading off for the
pirates 2-2 pitch
another one beat into the ground plenty
of time here for adamus
and there is out number one and the
ground balls keep coming for adrian
hauser gamble draws a one-out walk
runner takes off that's going to keep
him out of a double play
another ground ball out but gamal
started
with the pitch and a runner at scoring
position now as newman rolls out
now runner in scoring position and two
away for phillip evans
and that's a called strike three so
there's an open door on the outside
corner baker working to jackie bradley
jr here's the pitch swinging and a miss
struck him out high and away fastball
and one out in the fifth inning a nice
job of going back upstairs with the
fastball
strike three call so brubaker has
retired seven in a row
no hits since the bradley home run in
the second three to one the brew crew
leading the pirates
that's a well-hit ball left field gelech
will turn and he'll stop around first
there's a nice swing by yeli that looked
more like it
kept that bat on the same plane adamus
hit a breaking ball out in the first
inning
hit the glove of brubacher
and frazier has no play that's going to
go as an infield hit for adamus
on base for the third time yelich to
second they were pinched up the middle
they might have a chance of double play
actually yeah that in effect if he
catches it he might be able to spin
around and turn a double play but
brewers have first and third with one
out tyrone taylor hitting 2-0 the count
and taylor into right center that is
going to get down it's going to go to
the wall
yell it scores easily adamus around
third on his way he'll score
taylor in the third of belly flop triple
two rbis for tyrone taylor yeah there
they go again those guys we were talking
about when we came on the air today
a ringing triple into the gap there's a
lot of room out there big outfield in
pittsburgh and with tyrone taylor's
speed
he's able to get into third base
one out and luis urriaz who has struck
out all three times he's glad brubaker's
out of the game
five
four
three
very nice
well hayes could get that started so
quick talking about that young fan that
made the play
last night reaching over the railing and
making that catch it was a tremendous
play but he also has a bat signed by
christian yelich that he's been holding
up and showing the crowd quite a bit
it's pretty cool gesture oliver oh for
two ground out in a strikeout runner at
second
and a strikeout hauser powers one inside
oliver's gone strikeout number five for
adrian is on the edge or that late
movement in off the plate two outs and a
runner at first and craig council is
going to come take the ball from
adrian hauser who is at 103 pitches
and he got two on for one of the better
hitters in the national league right now
and adam frazier
broke his back little roller out to
second base peterson will put it away
and sooner does the job reynolds who
doubled back in the first inning
it's this one a long way and is bradley
gonna make this catch no way
a bomb
into the
pirate bullpen
sets off the fireworks
number 15
for reynolds here's ben gale
turns on one that's deep in the right
and taylor makes the catch
up against the wall tyrone taylor
takes a hit away from gammel
[Music]
brewers keep flashing that leather he
got to the wall had the taylor able to
swipe third base
and now hira dumps one right field base
hit
taylor will score an insurance run for
the brewers
six to two milwaukee back-to-back hits
from hira and now bradley and pablo
reyes will indeed hit
runners take off throw to third and out
here
here thinks he's safe council they'll
challenge it just to see
kerwin danley the crew chief on the
right and safe is the call
and that's gonna get by stalling it's a
wild pitch that goes out
one base here is in seven to two
milwaukee one pitch
defoe ground ball to short adamus
fittingly has it flips to jace peterson
at second they get the force out on
evans and the ball game is over the
brewers have won 10 straight